hey guys it is Friday thank God because
I have a backlog of games that is not
gonna play itself also we're in the park
because you guys like the puck that's
the birds in the traffic here's what's
been making news this week if you only
know one thing about horizon zero dawn
I'm betting it's robot dinosaurs and
possibly also that you can override them
but you can't control them gorillas have
come out to explain why the override
ability lets you change a machines
Allegiance so it will stop attacking you
and target threats against you but you
can't actually tell said critters to do
your machine destruction bidding
producer Sam Raj Sharma told Kotaku if
you look at the function of the machines
they all have a certain purpose within
the game you hacking them doesn't change
what they exist for it just changes
their Allegiance
you haven't changed their essential
functions he added that it doesn't make
sense in the game's lore to have a lie
ordering machines to go stomp on each
other in other Horizon II news a new
patch came out this week to address
crush and progression issues just like
Nintendo's main competitor in the 90s
the Nintendo switches going fast is now
the fastest selling console for the
company ever Australia Europe America's
the switch is broken sales records in
all three territories in its first week
on sale even beating out the phenomenon
that was the wave Nintendo of America
president Reggie fils-aime a told the
New York Times Nick Wingfield that the
initial 48-hour sales period in the
Americas exceeded the first two day
sales in the region for any system in
the company's history alongside a
success of the console The Legend of
Zelda breath of the wild is also the
best-selling standalone launch title in
the company's history
it even outperformed the initial sales
for Wii Sports in Australia which was
previously the biggest selling Nintendo
launch title ever in the region I mean
we do love our sport I assume we do I
mean I don't but someone must hey you
know what's an amazing game over watch
it's got this amazing girl robot in it
and she's a really cool tank so cool and
amazing that they're already nerfing her
before she's even available to the
public this week Jeff Caplan took to the
Blizzard forums to clarify that they're
holding off on releasing new character
IRISA to the public game until later in
March thanks to public testing they've
decided to nerf her primary weapon with
a smaller magazine and increase the cost
of her ulti ERISA is a tank class
character who focuses on defensive roles
and team
buff's speaking of buffs a bunch of
characters are getting them junk rat no
longer takes damage from his own
explosions sabra makes less noise
Winston's barrier starts cooling down
sooner and Zenyatta can target discord
through barriers however everyone's
favorite grandma Anna is getting some
serious nerfs her rifle deals less
damage and her biotic grenade does half
the healing and damage than it used to
great change is I reckon but tell me if
I'm wrong and then I'll argue with you
we don't have a pokemon ghost story in
the news this week so instead let's talk
about no man's sky which is mosey back
into the spotlight a massive update
arrived for the space exploring game
this week the Pathfinder update adds new
vehicles a permadeath mode so it's just
like real space-based sharing that lets
you share your base through Steam
Workshop a ship and weapons
specialization system and PlayStation 4
pro support all ships are now rated by
class and there are new EXO craft
vehicles so you don't have to move it
this speed across planets there's also a
photo mode improvements to the discovery
menu and general tweaks like I said big
update the new graphical changes include
high and ultra res textures more
accurate ambient lighting high contrast
lighting effects HDR mode horizon based
ambient occlusion and more hello games
added that 4k rendering on PC is now
optimized just when you thought you were
done with open-world action games 16
minutes of game players dropped from
Middle Earth shadow of war monolith
productions has revealed what to expect
when the dynamic duo of tallian and Cal
labrum bore celebr umber the elf guy
returned to lay waste to the hordes of
Sauron on August 22 the first game's
Nemesis system has been expanded
considerably with allies now creating
quite entirely new stories of loyalty
betrayal rivalry and even friendship
you'll also be able to take to the skies
on the back of dragons while taking part
in huge multistage battles shadow of war
is coming to ps4 Xbox one and PC and
will also be available on project
Scorpio though monolith are yet to
reveal what differences if any this
version will have this week on site if
you want to find out anything you've
ever wanted to know about The Legend of
Zelda breath of the wild we have like 80
million videos on sites
and now he is Dan reacting to youtubers
reacting to Dan reacting to the tastes
of Nintendo's switch cartridges that is
everything we've got be this week's
thanks so much again for tuning in and
be sure to subscribe to us if you like
the videos or just give us a like if
subscribe seems like a little too much
commitment I'll see you again on Monday
[Music]